[Music]
in addition to Super Bowl yesterday
yesterday was also Groundhog Day and
that in Punxsutawney Pennsylvania
Punxsutawney Phil apparently saw his
shadow and predicted six more weeks of
winter that's the big story yeah on the
East Coast now here in Hollywood we
don't have Punxsutawney Phil but we do
have Punxsutawney dr. Phil
now it's really nice to see you
Punxsutawney dr. Phil well I'm glad to
meet you yeah okay so how much more
winter do we have to look forward to
here in Los Angeles
you're young you're beautiful you're
intelligent you have all of these things
you have to decide that you are lovable
you have to decide that you are
acceptable that's great but I just want
to know how long winter is going to last
what are you so angry about I'm not
angry I just want to know the weather
that's your job the weather you have
black out anger is that true well told
you that according to your mother and
and your sister when you get upset you
become oftentimes violent that's not
that's not true I mean I have a temper
like anybody else but come on like tear
the house apart you've ripped towel bars
off the wall picked up knives and
threatened to slit people's throat it's
true Punxsutawney dr. Phil okay I'm
trying to help you you're you're siding
with that freak of nature no no wait a
minute I resent that all right okay I'm
sorry maybe maybe I do have a temper
problem how can you help me I will help
you every way that I can
I will get you professional help I will
do anything and everything I can to help
you and if I refuse your help then I
will kill you then he's just gone all
right well don't forget you can catch
the Punxsutawney dr. Phil show weekdays
at 4:00 we hear that's the stupidest
thing I've seen in a while where we are
eight spice up the real the real dr.
Phil what are you gonna what are you
going to do dr. Phil what are you gonna
do now then I will kill you okay that
would spice up the real dr. Phil that
would be so great